what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
40 year old dominic's single mom wants
to get married and make spice babies um
before i start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos if you
guys have any videos that you want me to
react to please send them to me on
instagram it's just
dot pearly things that's just dot pearly
things also if you've watched three or
more of my videos and you do not
subscribe yet me and you have beef
beef okay
beef all right i'm gonna play this uh
how old are you
i am 40 years old oh no all right so she
looks good for 40. i'm not even gonna
lie to you
she looks good about this whole thing
about the uh
emotional labor and women being too
tired for relationships what do you
think i think that they need to work out
and do some squats
i think that they need to get it like
like get their their workout on no
matter their age or their their size or
their
situation
that's how they feel
well now i want you to understand
that a lot of the women i'm talking
about work out
it's not a matter of them being
physically tired
mentally
yes okay emotional
labor
men's complaints they are women don't
act like women
i'd agree yeah they don't i do think
that
being in the workforce for so long kind
of does that to you like you lose a
little bit of your femininity just
because
i mean especially if you have an
emotionally demanding job i could see
that i don't
personally have one
at all like a job
so i wouldn't know but
i can see that that's the emotion the
femininity
maybe men have an imprecise way of
saying it
do you realize that look at look at
women today do most women walk around
looking like they're light
no they look like
they look like they're heavy like they
have a lot on their mind they look like
they're so what does it have to be
they're working miles
so what does it have so what is going to
the gym if they already go to the gym
see what do you do for a living i well i
am a
i'm a doula
and i'm just a doula i gotta google that
light as a dominatrix what the
oh my
a dominatrix
is that like when you whip people
i happen to have oh no a situation where
i also take care of
people in different circles like as a
doula it's not just that i'm in the
birth room i could be taking care of
people
because they're dealing with cancer or
all kinds of things or but you don't
have a job to go to that you're going to
report to eight to five every day no no
i work
yeah when was the last time you had to
do that if ever
a long time ago
yeah and and when i'm not doing that i'm
a broadcaster and i'm an actress
okay but when was the last time you had
to have the clock punch a clock i can't
even remember maybe
um well as an actress i punch a clock if
i'm on set
no that's not the same no it's not the
same no
so
you're not even talking about a world
that you are living
i live here
i live no you don't live in yeah and
that's the thing i feel like as women
we always want to talk about [ __ ]
like we always got to give our opinion
on everything
me too that's why i have this channel
i'm not above it
but
i watch my mom work for a very long time
and i do think it can be done because my
mom was very feminine like she cooked
she cleaned but she also worked for my
dad
but
i think there's something about being
able to make your own schedule that just
makes you a lot happier of a person
altogether
okay ma'am you're a doula and a creative
okay
no problem yeah but you don't have
women who heard you say all this [ __ ]
don't say who the hell is this chick she
don't even have a job
she don't have budgets and a staff and
that's what i'm saying
i'm just saying
you but i know you're but but i need you
to time out time okay okay you get you
gotta understand you're talking about
something that you have do you
understand their world
well these are my clients who come to me
for do you understand their world your
clients
don't you whip people for a lit i'm so
confused am i missing something i see
their world
i mean you understand do you no no you
service them do you understand their
world
i've left you don't
no you don't understand their world so
you don't understand
it doesn't matter whether you want to
and this is one of the problems that
women have
even when they look at my content they
think we don't get it so you can't just
talk at people and tell them what they
need to do if you don't understand their
world you don't have a job a a
structured job where you got to get to
so where do you come telling them that
they need to work out and i told you
that these women work out a lot of these
women work out to go to work they're not
i was just out i was just talking to two
very accomplished women who were in
great shape
because they can also learn something
from the spiritual woman the artist
woman to be a feminine woman and so
even though they're not i'm so
how is she feminine
if she's a dominatrix
am i
did i misunderstand her job
she said dominate jerks and doula if i
google doula
oh it's d-o-u-l-a
doula meaning it says
a woman um
oh so and
she helps women give birth
i'm so confused
okay i'll just continue looking at me as
a certain way these are the same women
who are knocking at my door asking me to
teach them how to be you know softer and
more gentle and move have movement in
their bodies because even though i'm
working out i might just do weights but
i'm also doing yoga or i'm doing a you
know spiritual are you married are you
are you single are you married i'm
single any children
yes one daughter
how does her daughter she's 16. she
travels and she does a lot of things and
she's my mom's travel companion and she
speaks different like three different
languages and
oh wow all right who's who's funny who's
funding that you
well
my mom and i we have our own business as
holistic practitioners and we support
people in rejuvenation of the body and
so okay so no i'm just going to say most
people will listen to what you're saying
they're called a very
liberal kind of way of living very hands
up most people can't live like that man
yeah
and that's the thing
you have to understand that most people
like a lot of the examples that girls
call into the show are the exception and
not the rule
and that's the problem is as women we
always want to live as the exception to
the rule
but
and that's what
that's why girls get so emotional and
we'll always be like not all women or i
know that certain person and i've done
it at times but you have to understand
that your world isn't the world and
that's a really that's a hard concept to
be honest
okay i grew up in so tell us
okay i get it i get it but but at the
end of the day you're not in a
relationship
true
so these women won't relate
no see
see what i'm trying to get you to
understand is you can still be right and
be wrong you're not
you're not in a relationship
you don't have a job
do you want to be a wife absolutely yes
i do oh no
oh no
oh no
oh no i know where this is going
i just know this is going to be bad oh
no why why why do you want to be a wife
because i want to raise a family i love
i love teaching my daughter other
languages i love homeschooling her i
love teaching her about the world and
the planet and how her role in it and be
able to create a legacy so she can so i
can have children that can take on this
world and be able to passionately i'm
just plugging in my phone and just be
able to passionately take a stance and
and you know do their part i don't want
to be the kind of like i'm just okay
hold on
yeah
how much time do you have left
you're already above a certain age
and that's the thing whenever i say this
to girls i swear to god i say this all
the time that we only have a finite
amount of time to have kids and have a
family and the immediate like gut
reaction that we have as a woman is well
i know that exception or well you can do
in vitro and that's totally true but do
you have forty thousand dollars to spend
on that
or my aunt's sister's mom or whatever
had a kid at this age like it's always
the exception never the rule she's going
for almost 30 seconds
you didn't say a goddamn thing about a
man
well i would support my husband and i
was going to say that too she doesn't
say anything about what the guy would
want it's always about what her and what
she likes to do
but when you have a family it's not
about you anymore nothing is about you
being able to make sure no no i know
stop stop
you just ran off at the mouth talking
about you want to have a daughter and
teaching about the the sun the moon the
stars the broccoli and the kale
and you didn't say one flipping thing
about what you're going to do for a man
well i really know what i i figured
that
okay you want to know i'll tell you so
what i want to do for my man
is without without a man there's no
marriage
i understand that i want you guys to
understand how many times i want you
guys to understand how many times i talk
to women about being wives and i ask
them why they want to be wise the first
thing they start talking about is what
they want out of it they skip right past
the men men don't exist
men do exactly
okay like where's your child's father
why didn't you guys marry
um
well my daughter's father and i didn't
marry because he was physically abusive
um
i don't know
see kevin
it's tough because kevin
i think his gut
typically is to quit he's going to
question this because
sometimes girls say that stuff happened
and it didn't but sometimes they're
telling the truth so it's kind of hard
to tell but i'm going to see what he
says
then why did you give him a baby
um we well what happened was honestly i
met him we weren't together very long i
got pregnant and and i realized that he
had a whole family that i didn't know
about oh no i left him because i wasn't
let's not get too i've been bet i've
been bamboozled by children before too
i could tell you guys a story about that
one oh my gosh
in all fairness why should women listen
to what you have to say
um that's what women are gonna ask
that's what they're gonna because you
said these are the same women who come
and ask you questions so tell ladies why
they should listen to what you haven't
said well that was many years ago and my
daughter is 16 now and where i i i've
taken my time to study a lot of
different courses from mastery over sex
to sex therapy why should women listen
to you about relationships i'm saying
this is what i'm saying and the reason
why is because
no i am not married but what i do know
is this i do know that there is a set of
rules that reside inside of a family to
be that backbone of a man and where to
have his back and so this way he can go
to work was the last time you're in a
relationship but that's
that's womanies for basically
there is no reason
i have no credibility
oh gosh
oh gosh um
i
like i said i moonlight at the
dominatrix so i do have when was the
last time you're in a relationship these
are relationships i don't know if you
could who's the last time you no no no
wait wait
her clients
she's in a relationship with her clients
what last time
marriage i haven't been no
never you know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
never
at 40
okay respectfully
how can you give relationship advice if
you've never been
in a relationship
oh that's so weird that's so weird well
that doesn't mean i'm not successful at
supporting let me just mean you don't
have an opinion no that doesn't mean i
don't have success ma'am listen listen
listen listen
may i ask you a question no you can
listen i've let you speak rather freely
okay
you coming here telling what women what
they should do okay and i'm just ask i
need you to shut the french toast up for
a second okay
you're not dominating [ __ ] here i'm not
trying to i'm trying to get you to
understand man is when women
we're talking about something
a subject i think is very serious me too
and i'm just trying to okay but you
don't have
you're not in a relationship you don't
have a job never be men okay but neither
kevin has two failed marriages
and i know what he says i could be
married and that's totally true but
can't women say the same thing
he definitely has more experience than
her though she's never been in a
relationship at 40 oh gosh
you're telling women what they need to
do and then they're going to say why
should we listen to you and you haven't
said why they should listen to you and
you say you want to get married and i'm
like
you one of these earthy kind of chicks
what's wrong with being earthy
nothing except the outcomes you your
mind
[Laughter]
oh my god
no
no
oh no no man no nothing no they're air
man you didn't you didn't let me you you
got you got me that you beat my mom is
no i didn't mean to be i did not say i
mean
don't play with me don't play me i can
do this without you what kind of
marriage would you like how would a
marriage look in your world how about
that a marriage in my world would be
more so that i'd prefer the man to be
dominant and take the lead i honestly do
want that i desire does he go to jail
you have to understand that who you are
is a production of your habits like the
habits that you have every single day
so how is the guy going to take the lead
if you're in the habit
of beating guys
oh gosh or i guess she said she doesn't
oh my goodness oh my goodness does he go
to work every day
if that's what supports the the family
role yeah
are you going to support the family is
he going to support the family no both i
create products and i have a product
line that i work with
are you out again i am 40 years old
and you said you want more children
i want one more child yes
do you live with your mother live with
you
um yeah my mom actually so you expect a
you expect a man to come marry a
40-year-old woman who got us
and have her mama lived there with a 16
year old attraction i didn't i didn't
say all that i support where where where
oh gosh
i don't know if i could live with my mom
that old
yeah i could who am i kidding
i love being at home
what what am i i'm capping i could live
with my parents forever i think i like
them too much
but but
that that would be quite odd for a guy
to come in and do mama
my mom lives in her own house this is
about i said does your mama live with
you that's why oh no she does not live
in my home all right that's because i
thought you said okay no we have our own
separate house
okay
okay never mind never mind i retract it
i retract okay let's back up 40 years
old you want to be mayor yes
all right
not really a traditional kind of
marriage set up though
a traditional kind of marriage yeah
where their gender roles yeah
yeah okay all right
i don't i don't think that a woman being
died i don't understand how you can have
a traditional marriage if you're a
dominatrix
i i
call me old-fashioned call me crazy i
don't know
but
okay honey
have a good day at work let me just go
beat some guys
for fun
oh god
it means that she has to be domineering
i think that she has to guide the ship
in other words be a person who's ready
to guide um okay but that's oh wait on
what the husband says as the lead and be
able to delegate do you think you could
be a dominatrix and a wife at the same
time well i think maybe dominatrix has a
terminology for you that you're putting
on i just asked or ma'am
i asked you could you be a wife at a
dominatrix
i'm okay so
aside from being a dominatrix
i just answered that question
this is lady answer the question
yes or no it's okay if the answer is no
i would get a different job that could
be your answer
i just use what the french toast words
you use the words
can you be a wife and a dominatrix
i think what is what's coming may i be
completely honest i want to answer your
question but i want to be complete the
word dominatrix has many different
looks
i don't care ma'am
you use the word you didn't you didn't
provide a thesaurus i'm just asking can
you be the word you used and a wife
if that's what my husband prefers
there's a lot of men the answer is
the answer is yes oh no yes there are
men who request to have that kind of
experience with me and yes they are no
no no no no no no no no no
oh no this is the this is the problem
with women is
women we get so much attention on the
daily
that we assume that just because the guy
is giving us attention that he would
date us
when a lot of guys that are giving us
attention they just want to sleep with
you
there's a very big difference between
sexual attention and relationship
attention
and
as women like i think we need to do
better
about discerning like what is the
difference and it's hard i'm not saying
that's easy but
i can't this one is pretty easy if you
you have a client
as a dominatrix
i can't imagine that screams i want to
date you call me old-fashioned
call me crazy i don't know man i mean
can you still be a dominatrix
and a wife dominatrix doesn't mean i
have to do that with many people it's
just with one person so in other words
this is why it's with one person oh my
gosh i have so many questions i wish
you'd let her talk a little longer
because i got questions i would like to
be a dominatrix with my husband but i do
not
have fun
how can you say it's a traditional
marriage
if you want to be
a dominatrix with your husband what is
going on i can't even believe these
people are real sometimes
like i genuinely think they're fake at
times in the bedroom privately
most men who go looking for wives aren't
looking for
these new age relationships
they're just not
the world you live in sounds like a
complete joke to most people i'm not i'm
not casting any judgment i'm really not
but the way you're talking
no ma'am i i need you to
but he's this is again as women i think
we naturally get defensive and it's hard
when someone's attacking what you do for
a living but
he's letting her know how the world
views her he's not saying that's how he
views her and
that he's judging but he's just letting
her know
that this is how people are going to see
you if that's the career path that you
choose i let you speak now let me speak
i'm on a show talking about a topic
and you don't have a job talking about
what women need to do about their job
they do have a job all right i need i
need you say one more thing to cut me
off and i'm going to bid you a good
night
can you control yourself
thank you
all i'm saying man is
your world is very small and niche and
i'm trying to understand how what you're
saying is going to be helpful to anybody
outside of your world
tell the women what you have that that
you can give them that's going to help
them in their existence not yours
it depends on where the woman is coming
from i don't know where all your i don't
know where your demographic of your the
people most people have jobs and they're
not dominations most women have don't
have 16 year olds to travel both of them
happen in school
oh she laughed i was not expecting that
that's what i thought this would tell
you dude
and that's the thing
that's why i always on my channel i
always tell you guys
that i came from a very privileged
background i came from i had a very good
upbringing i don't relate to a lot of
the things
that i see on the internet but
oh my gosh a dominatrix oh my god you
want to be a housewife
and a dominate
dominatrix good luck
oh my goodness
can't make this [ __ ] up i can't even
believe this is real oh my gosh okay
guys
um
that was a fun one that was fun
um before i end the video don't forget
to subscribe leave a comment and let me
know if you would wife a dominatrix
and don't forget to subscribe i will
talk to you guys next time